all right I'm not going to do this to
you even every week never mind every day
for the next two years but because last
night failed former president Donald
Trump announced another run for
president in 2024 we have to look at
what the polling says right now not only
about Trump versus other Republicans but
also general election polling I was
telling you earlier we have a very
different situation now for Trump's run
than we did in 2016 or 2020. now Donald
Trump number one has become a clear
loser 2018 wasn't great for Republicans
2020 was a disaster for Trump and
Republicans and 2022 was the red wave
that I guess could have been but wasn't
for republicans and so now you have a
republican electorate not completely
sick of and tired of trump but certainly
much more so than in years past and you
have a guy that is very well liked among
Republicans and that is Ron DeSantis the
governor of Florida who was just
re-elected by a 19 nearly 20 point
margin that is a blowout win for Ron
DeSantis we don't yet know the impact of
last night's announcement it that Donald
Trump is running on the polling but we
do have a bunch of polls released after
the November 8th midterms and they're
very bad for Donald Trump let's take a
look at this you can find this on the
538 Republican primary 2024 page and
what we see is that there is a seven
letter Insight poll released today that
shows Ron DeSantis plus eight over
Donald Trump still with a lot of
undecideds we do have a single morning
consult poll from yesterday that still
shows Trump ahead by 14 over DeSantis
but then we have a CWS research poll
looking at Texas which has DeSantis plus
11 over Donald Trump in Georgia Florida
New Hampshire and Iowa
WPA intelligence polls which are okay
they're rated A B C by 538 all have Ron
DeSantis ahead between plus 11 and plus
26. we have a legere poll of the
national Republican primary which has
the DeSantis at plus two and then we
have a yougov poll which is the best
ranked pollster of all of these at a B
plus with Ron DeSantis plus seven Rhonda
santis plus seven this is a very
different situation than in years past
we will maybe know by Monday maybe next
Tuesday or Wednesday what the polling
looks like after Trump's announcement
will Trump's announcement help him in
that it will invigorate people to say
okay DeSantis isn't even running Trump's
running I'm throwing my support behind
Trump or
will Trump's early announcement which
was ill-advised according to many
right-wing strategists actually hurt
Trump that would be an interesting thing
to see now also notable and again I'm
not going to do this to you every day or
even every week for the next two years
if we look at general election polls for
2024 and it is so early but it is still
interesting if you look at a new poll
released by legere again A B C pollster
in a hypothetical Biden versus Trump
matchup it is Biden plus three and in a
hypothetical Biden versus DeSantis
matchup it is DeSantis plus two in that
poll DeSantis polling way better and
then in a bunch of different Biden polls
for 2024 from morning consult it is
Biden winning in every single one it's
Biden defeating Christy Cheney Pompeo
Rick Scott Hogan gnome Tim Scott Tom
Cotton Holly Cruz Haley Romney Rubio
says the best outcome is DeSantis
DeSantis is the only one that in that
poll is even even
with Joe Biden and then this one from
right before the election uh actually
this is from New York New York's a very
blue State kind of meaningless okay so
the other point here is
Trump and other Republicans short of Ron
DeSantis aren't even polling well in
hypothetical matchups against Joe Biden
Joe Biden also hasn't announced that
he's running in 2024. so a very
different situation here
we are taking a picture right now
and then we're going to give it six or
so months and see how things are looking
in the spring but it is not at all clear
even though many Republicans insist this
nomination is Trump's for the taking it
is not clear that it is really Trump's
for the taking and it is not at all
clear that if Trump wins that nomination
that he is in a strong position to
actually win in 2024. at which point by
the way he will be you know nearly 80
years old and that's a whole other story
which we will get to the point is this
could all end in genuine historic
humiliation for Donald Trump
you've heard me talk about the accounts
we've had hacked it's a horrible
experience it can happen to anyone look
up the stats if it hasn't happened to
you yet it may at some point protecting
yourself against scammers online can get
complicated our sponsor Aura is the
all-in-one solution that I now use to
keep accounts safe Aura scans the dark
web for your personal info emails
passwords Social Security numbers
immediately alerts you if anything is
found helps you fix the problem you also
get alerts about suspicious credit
inquiries or automatically request the
removal of your information from search
engines and data broker sites and Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware with its state-of-the-art
antivirus and Aura also helps you manage
what your kids can do on their devices
with very simple easy to use parental
device controls you can try or a free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman your
login credentials might already be
floating around it takes only a few
seconds on Aura to figure that out and
think of all of the other useful things
you'll discover during the two-week
trial the link is down below